[Music]
hey there
my name's christina treister christina
is a fight master
fight director and certified teacher
with the society of american fight
directors
she's also an associate professor of
acting and stage combat at the
university of michigan
today i'll be breaking down clips from
movies and tv
about sword fighting tactical advantage
game of thrones i always drink before a
fight
could get you killed it could get me
killed you know
drinking before you're gonna go in and
try to
fight to the death would be a really
really bad idea
so we see two very different body types
and styles of fighting in here we see
what is
a whirling dervish kind of form with a
lot of
spinning that's happening a lot of
changing of levels going from full
height
down to a knee spinning away from your
opponent
he's also using um what is almost a
spear
a long quarter staff um with a spear
point on the end
and that is good for his body type
because he's keeping distance
between himself
so his use of movement is brilliant
because he is a moving target
at all times but what he's doing
is a lot of deflecting parries that are
happening
so as an attack's coming in he's moving
out of the way and deflecting the energy
of it
so that's how he's able to go up against
steel
i feel like martell is more fit
so that cardio advantage if the fight
went on longer
i think would have been to his advantage
versus the mountain
where he messes up as he lets his guard
down and
yet you haven't confessed say it
say her name and the mountain is genius
he just lays there and plays possum
right
until
and it's all over because he is
literally twice
his body weight
fighting when injured monty python look
you stupid
you've got no arms left yes i have look
just a flesh wound if it's just a flesh
wound as they say or a scratch you could
keep going
what are you gonna do bleed on me it
also depends upon the adrenaline dump
that happens right the endorphins that
start to kick in
i'm invincible but in terms of organs
being pierced
or losing arms and legs no how are you
come on then it's not very realistic but
is
hysterical all right we call it a draw
fencing techniques the princess bride
you're using bonnetti's defense against
me ah naturally you must expect me to
attack with capoferro but i find that
typical cancers are cap affair
unless the enemy has a study he's a
clipper
[Music]
so these terms agrippa bonnetti capofero
they're all actually people who were
fencing masters
in italy during the 16th century
although there is one dutch
dude that's in there no one of
consequences they're referring to
these men who were coming up for the
first time with manuals that could be
studied during that time
you are wonderful thank you i've worked
hard to become so
so what's really interesting about the
storytelling of this clip
is that neither one of these characters
has ever met their match before
why are you smiling because i know
something you don't know so
they start out with quick little moves
and what is that
i am not left-handed
then once they realize they finally have
someone that they could compete with
them they switch to their dominant hand
i'm not left-handed either
what we try to do a lot of times is
train with our non-dominant hand
to strengthen our dominant hand it also
helps to balance out our fighting styles
[Music]
so the one critique i would have about
this scene
is that the swords they're using are
almost rubbery
they're going so fast that they're
bending in frame
and if you're a nerd who's watched this
clip like seven
gazillion times you start noticing
things like that
i hate to kill you you seem a decent
feather i hate to die
one of the things that's great about
swashbuckling is a lot of times there's
a lot of humor in it
you're amazing i ought to be after 20
years and you see that in their cheeky
expressions and the delivery of their
lines
that are also in time with the
choreography so they're rocking it
thank you type of sword kill bill
this is steel
so hattori hanzo was a 16th century
japanese samurai warrior who was
amazing like he was the best of the best
and he had a nickname of
demon hanzo because he quote unquote
fought like hell so he really was a
historical character
there is an insignia on the sword that
lets you
know the type that it is and this was
actually a common tradition with many
armorers
not just for a katana but also in
european martial arts as well
everyone knew if you had a sword from a
high quality armorer
you pretty much knew what you were doing
and had trained a lot
or you had money
so the bride fights all of these people
to get to this moment
[Music]
her sword would absolutely be dull if
she had taken down
that many opponents
now it could still be feasible but that
this move could happen
because it is like the ultimate of the
ultimate of all samurai swords
[Music]
but yeah you would need to sharpen your
sword shields
troy
it's actually one of my my biggest pet
peeves is when fighters start too close
this is awesome because you need those
first opening moments to kind of size
your opponent up
see where they are physically see where
they are psychologically emotionally
all of those things you're trying to
find the advantage that you can get
so it absolutely makes sense that you
would start out of distance and then
slowly work your way in
shields are awesome because they're not
just defensive weapons they can also be
used
offensively as well there are things
called shield
bashes where you get your body behind
the shield
and essentially turn yourself into a
battering ram
you can see they're armored their legs
are exposed their arms are exposed and
this fight their head is exposed
so you could slice with the end of that
i mean we all know that
thinner metal you can cut yourself on it
so if you're using that with some force
behind it
it could turn into an offensive weapon
as well
so we do see two different shields in in
this clip and they're completely
historically accurate there were all
kinds of shapes and sizes
so we see in brad pitt's shield that he
uses the notches on the side
to rest his weapon at one point it's
kind of like picking different kinds of
swords different kinds of shields after
training with them for many years you
would find
out kind of what your favorite was and
what kind of played to your strengths as
a warrior
so shields like anything else are
they're heavy right
it's it's a big piece of metal so you're
having to work from your core
a lot
even though these men are both very fit
there's only
so much that your rotator cuff can take
in terms of torque
right so it makes sense towards the end
that
they are becoming more fatigued
they're ditching their shields and just
going for the weapons
that are going to impact the other
opponent
and inflict some damage to them
fencing terminology i love you man
bro really sorry i lost my out
there i just did not see the name
cortada coming oh hey man don't worry
you know you came in with a pretty sweet
glaze so what's cracking me up
about this clip and why it just i'm
sorry seems so bad
is that they're mispronouncing the first
two terms
which could easily have been looked up
and quite glazed
these are all french terms and not that
you have to be hoity-toity-french when
you say them but it is definitely not
glazad glazad it's glizzod
in cortada he almost gets right
but it's just everything is so
anglicized
with american pronunciation
that it takes away any value that these
guys have been studying this stuff for
years
wow way to go buddy in cortada and
glizad are actually
moves in fencing anybody see my man
do you look under your plaster on the
quicker the last two
terms are items of equipment
the first being gloves the second being
the protective quilted
vest in a sense that protects your
organs
it's like they have no sense of what
they're saying
what's also funny is this locker room is
set up
like it's a sport like basketball or
football and they
they just have their foils hanging there
in the locker room which
would not be the case um they're metal
they will rust you need to oil them down
you need to store them properly it's not
just having
like racks of basketballs on the side
sportsmanship
hook
[Music]
yes it was very unsportsmanlike for hook
to use his hook to slice peter's wrist
he's absolutely right that they are
engaged in this combat
and hook is essentially cheating bad
form would be kind of an archaic way to
to show that you were not pleased with
the way that hook was performing
but then you kind of have to go well
he's a pirate
so is there any code of conduct with
pirates
no he's just a mean old man
[Music]
the maneuver that peter is using to
disarm hook is an
envelopment with an expulsion he
effectively
parries hook's attack and then with a
really quick revolution of his wrist
he swings that around close and
takes it removes it from hook's hand
and then uses another flick of his wrist
to send it
soaring onto the ground
you see peter trying to be sportsmanlike
and hook coming in and
playing dirty but in the end it still
doesn't matter
because peter's technique is better than
hooks
good form peter two on one
star wars the phantom menace
whenever you have two against one in
theory
it should be harder for the one to
defend against the two
and the two had a lot of tactical
advantages
so they should have been attacking him
at the same time they could have started
both facing off with him so that he had
to defend two things or if they
are behind there's a lot of vulnerable
parts that they could have been
attacking
[Music]
when darth maul runs away he is using
divide and conquer right he's trying to
separate them but then you see young
obi-wan just kind of sauntering
over to him i don't understand why
that's not a running attack
and why they're not still pressing him
so if you're darth maul you're trying to
take one opponent at a time you don't
want to fight to it once
we see that he finally has success when
he's able to
separate those opponents between the
dividers and can take them on one at a
time
sparks blade
so if you hit blades completely edge to
edge you wouldn't have as much spark but
if you're angling things slightly
so it has to do with the trajectory and
the force combined that would create it
to have this amount of sparks you would
obviously have to have
some effects that were being laid in in
post-production to create that
every time that you do that you are
inflicting damage on the edge
of your sword creating burrs little
divots
that are going to have to be dealt with
to maintain a sharp edge
and over time it would immeasurably keep
deteriorating
i mean they're immortal so they probably
don't care if they're doing damage to
their blades
some are always trying to
ice skate uphill
teaching game of thrones who are you
you're dancing master serio pharrell
tomorrow you will catch it so in this
clip we see a very young arya
right with syrio her teacher who is
teaching her
the beginning fundamentals of sword play
what is the proper stance what is the
way you should hold the sword
what is the fluidity that you should
have with the weapon
that is not the way boy it is not a
great sword that is needing two hands to
swing it
it's too heavy and we can see right away
that when you've never held anything
like this it's it's kind of a
intricate multi-layered concept it is
heavy as it needs to be
to make you strong
just so one hand is all that is needed
the grip must be delicate there's
actually a
phrase that says you want to hold the
sword
like a bird not so tight that you crush
it
but not so loose that it flies away and
what you mean by that is that you want
to have control of
over the sword but if you strong arm it
and
grip it tight you're going to lose
fluidity
and reaction all of that so they're
doing a fencing style
that is all about a piercing weapon how
it's not
something that you would handle roughly
like a battle axe but it's something
that's light
and fluid that's all pretty good
so for this particular weapon style her
frame is perfect because she's quick and
light kind of like a mosquito
right just moving fluidly and going fast
[Music]
very dead there are several times within
it that
there are cutting techniques those are
attacks that are used with the edge of
the weapon as opposed to
thrusts which are used with the sharp
point of the sword we're not looking to
cut
limbs we're literally thinking of it as
a needle that is trying to poke organs
quick and fatal and you could bleed out
easier
just so fighting in a parking garage
[Music]
highlander
so they use the environment in an
interesting way
[Music]
i mean it's cool to fight on top of car
hoods i don't know if you really need to
run across them i don't know if you need
to be flipping off of a car hood
when you could just jump i would be
using these cars
as ways to hide and try to surprise my
opponent
these swords now after the sprinkler
system
is hit and after the electricity
is compromised they're basically running
around with lightning rods almost
that are going to be conduits for
electricity
the other thing that confuses me is the
round off back handsprings
[Music]
i'm not sure how you would do those with
your sword
there's a lot more tactical things that
you could
do with this environment rather than
kind of throwing everything in the
kitchen
sink with trying to make things more
fantastical and
quote-unquote cool moves of the 80s
weapon selection crouching tiger hidden
dragon
[Music]
i love the selection of the first weapon
style because it's an effect
double fence
she's using two swords one in dominant
and non-dominant hand
and you really with the choreography get
to see what what it would be like to
have
two weapons against one i also love it
because it starts off with her strong
suit
so she's clearly choosing the weapons
that she feels more comfortable with
so what's so great about this clip is
that you see
michelle yeo's character is is older way
more experienced
[Music]
her character brings this vast
experience of all these different weapon
[Music]
forms
to have that level of expertise you
would have had to have been
studying your entire life to be able to
work with all those different weapons
you're gonna keep picking the ones that
you feel strongest until you're down to
with what you've got
now what is great is that her opponent
would need to know the strengths
and weaknesses of each of the other
weapon styles so that she would know
how to wear those weapons down either
how to disarm them
to destroy them or to keep her opponent
on the move
different types of opponents gladiator
he has two weapons a sword and an axe
and then russell crowe's character has a
gladius and a shield
you're both double fence you're both
have your sword in your dominant hand
and your additional weapon in your
others
[Applause]
so i think russell crowe actually is
doing a good job he's using that shield
to deflect blows as much as possible
particularly with the axe
and he's also using it as an offensive
weapon
[Applause]
when the tide turns between the two of
them it's because he took the edge of
his shield
and knocked that helmet
and then immediately goes for the
vulnerable part right the foot
even though maximus decimus meridius is
like
an amazing tried-and-true soldier on the
battlefield he's essentially a prisoner
of war
this other guy is still way bigger than
he is
so it it could go either way you could
say
that the larger guy could have the upper
hand
because it's a smaller playing space
[Applause]
[Music]
but russell crowe is just a better
fighter in the end he's faster he never
stops moving
he changes levels he's keeping his eye
on all parts of his playing area you
simply won't
die it's that whole thing of wearing
your opponent down
really comes into play with this and
taking them by surprise
grabbing a blade rob roy
you would definitely have damage if you
grabbed a blade and we can see
that with rob roy what lends itself for
us to believe him a little bit more are
a couple of things the first being that
he's ginormous so you kind of
buy that he could grab that the second
thing is that it's
it's a desperation move it's the end of
the fight
you will always sacrifice this to
protect your core
so even if you did shred your hand it's
better than being dead
so there is a bit of willing suspension
of disbelief in this clip
because it feels like tim roth his
character is
waiting a bit if someone had grabbed the
end of my blade
i would just pull that to do more damage
those are all lost
opportunities to essentially finish off
that character
sharps versus sporting swords
die another day
you want to continue of course i want to
bloody continue
but since we're upping the wager let's
up the weapon shall we so the term
sharps versus a sporting
sword or a stage combat sword
the sharps are are what we would call
live weapons right
something that is a real sword that is
sharpened
to a point a sporting sword or a
theatrical sword
those have dull edges and dull points
the ones that we train with with actors
are actual real weapons they're just not
sharpened
but you still have to teach safe
technique for them because they
they could still do damage honk out
so we're looking at traditional foils
with all of the protective gear
in the sporting version of the match
there's a little kind of error that i'm
seeing here and that
the protective gauntlet the glove comes
up purposely to protect the wrist
portion of your sword-fighting hand
but i don't see how that foil tip with a
button
could have gotten to skin to make that
happen
let's do this the old-fashioned way
first blood drawn from the torso
once they switch to the sharps they're
getting sabers
that have a cutting edge any rules can
be set
whenever you're dueling in a traditional
sense
you set those rules those terms
before you have the match
you can see in the beginning when they
switched to sabers that they're
they're starting on a line and they're
starting with a little bit of form
although they have more cut they have
cutting attacks
but then once the first point of danger
and the injury happens
all of that form goes out the window
once it's the stakes are up and they're
using sharps
they take off all of their protective
gear and the fighting style
starts to evolve in a sense and becomes
more flailing
[Music]
conclusion overall i would say that
hollywood
tends to get right about these clips
that
sword fighting is exciting it's
something that
is otherworldly that we understand but
it's
we don't normally see people in everyday
life fighting with swords
an actual duel an actual sword fight a
lot of times would be very quick
but it also wouldn't be as entertaining
to see on the big screen